so yes one way to create the index
configuration file is to actually
manually edit it and another way to get
the indexes correct is to run the
queries on localhost before you update
the app to app spot this one here
annotate the properties at auto index is
incorrect I just made this up this at
auto index however you do have to
annotate your properties as at index if
you want them to be indexed at all and
actually yes you don't have to worry
about single property queries because
indexes are automatically created for
every property that is marked with at
index so the only thing you have to
worry about for your single property
queries is to make sure that the
property itself has got the at index
annotation